dans l'histoire de l'art rares sont les
artistes que l'on étudie au regard de
leur appartenance religieuse
c'est le cas de sébastien bourdon pour
son appartenance à l'église réformée
sébastien bourdon est connu comme l'un
des peintres religieux du xviie siècle
cet artiste né en 1616 à montpellier
c'est un des premiers fondateurs de
l'académie de peinture en 1648 il en est
les recteurs la partie importante de
cette exposition
ce serait de montrer que contrairement à
une croyance
il existe de la peinture religieuse dans
les églises réformées essentiellement
l'église luthérienne
il n'y a peu il ya peu des luthériens en
france au xviie siècle donc on connaît
peu la peinture luthérienne mais en tout
cas la peinture religieuse n'est pas une
exclusivité du monde catholique
c'est quelque chose de sans doute un peu
neuf parce que on imagine effectivement
qu' il n'y a pas de peinture chez les ch
et les protestants alors qu'il y en a
avec ses oeuvres de miséricorde
l'artiste choisi un sujet au coeur de la
controverse religieuse
ils représentent des personnages de
l'ancien testament bien connu par les
protestants il se dégage de la série
peinte comme de la série graver une
impression dramatique
les peintures étaient forcément vu par
un public très restreint
alors que la gravure et tels moyens de
diffusion au xviie siècle il n'y avait
pas de photographier donc pour faire
connaître son oeuvre on les faisait
graver alors les collectionneurs faisait
graver leurs collections pour la mettre
en valeur
et puis les peintres pour montrer leur
travail et le coup naturellement des
graveurs était bien moindre que celui
des peintures toutes les oeuvres de
sébastien bourdon sont à découvrir lors
de l'exposition au musée national de
port royal des champs qui se poursuit
jusqu'au 16 décembre
[Musique]
et